hi welcome to science hangout
I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission we
have today dr. James Eber wine professor
of pharmacology and translational
therapeutics co-director penn program in
single cell biology at the University of
Pennsylvania School of Medicine with us
dr. Eber wine has published hundreds of
research articles and is in the
editorial board of several journals and
has won several awards and is an expert
in single-cell analysis welcome dr. Eber
wine thank you for the invitation to
join you I'm looking forward to our
discussion can you please tell us about
your background your education just
briefly go over your kind of a history
of what you have done so far sure I'd be
happy to so I I was born and raised I
was raised in Ohio and a small rural
town in Ohio which which was phenomenal
now my initial science interest came
from some high school teachers that I
had there who were phenomenal at
teaching you how to think about science
I'm afraid of so much science education
these days is reading and memorizing but
when these two teachers did was they
need experiments it had us do
experiments they had us think about no
observation and interpretation and and
so it's really really wonderful to be
able to have that grounding and then my
real formal introduction to science came
when I was a junior in high school and
my parents were kind enough to send me
to a National Science Foundation summer
program in science so used to be that
the National Science Foundation would
fund
high school programs all around the
country in various disciplines so my
parents who believe education is really
important
sent me to one on biochemistry in
Hartford Connecticut and so I spent two
weeks studying biochemistry text called
lenninger and and doing experiments and
and learning about science and so it's
really a formative experience that
really helped me know understand that I
wanted to be a scientist
from there I was fortunate to be able to
go to Yale as an undergraduate where I
majored in biochemistry and did lots of
philosophy I did a thesis in philosophy
and from there then I went to Columbia
as as a graduate student then a postdoc
at Stanford mm-hmm in 1990 I came to
University of Pennsylvania as its it's a
professor and started much much of my
independent work at that point and
became the Box professor of Pharmacology
in 1996 so I know Penn has been a great
environment for me I've really enjoyed
it among the things that I've really
valued in terms of education and and
thinking about science and I know that
you're very interested science education
as well is I was fortunate to be able to
start a cold spring harbor course when I
was a postdoc on molecular neurobiology
so 30 years ago well years ago I started
the cloning of neuro genes course at
quartz McCarver at that point there were
very few people doing molecular biology
in the nervous system so they asked me
as a postdoc to do it normally they have
professors do it so I started the course
and I directed it for a total of about
15 years off and on and so in the course
of lecture and then five years ago I
started another course at Cold Spring
Harbor on single cell biology and those
courses I don't know if you've been to
one but they are really phenomenal in
terms of bringing among the best
students from around the world who have
an interest in a particular discipline
to the lab to actually do didactic
education learning from papers and
lectures but also hands-on laboratory
experience doing experiments that they
might do back in their own lab applying
the techniques that they're learning so
so I think now that's a little bit of my
background and some of my interests and
and right now you know I consider myself
a molecular neurobiologists but also
genomicist and we do much of our work
and the level of single-cell analysis in
the central nervous system although we
do work
a whole host of other cell types as well
but you'll hear about some of that
during my formal presentation okay okay
then cuz I will do other lab people
laugh grad students postdocs yeah no no
it's it's a great question and one
that's critically important to modern
science I've been very fortunate to have
great graduates who the postdocs come
through my lab right now I have one
graduate student and yes by postdoc six
postdocs and excuse me four technicians
and the thing that I require of these
students whether they're a graduate
student or postdoc or even a technician
is their willingness to think creatively
you know in my lab we do a lot of new
technology development because the
questions that we try to address require
that they know technique answer the
questions that we're trying to develop
and to do that you have to be
open-minded you have to be able to
understand the technology you're
developing you have to be able to
understand when you need to use cobalt
or cadmium in your reactions and so you
have to be willing to think creatively
and to accept failure because often
times new technologies and new
approaches fail and so I'm fortunate
that have almost all the people through
my laboratory who are willing to think
open-mindedly and to approach science in
a creative fun way you know it's such a
great time to be able to do science now
there's so many question that what can
finally answer you can ask any question
you've been able to ask any question you
wanted you forever but can you actually
address those but now we really really
can do many of those so I think that's
really real and so the people allowed
have been very very conscientious about
and working in that manner mm-hmm yes I
think camera I stuck looks like
basically just if you can all right yeah
oh I'm not even seeing the camera now
see if that comes up huh for some reason
that coming up now you try it again okay
okay so one other question is like how
do you motivate them like I know like
people like a scientist want to have
their own motivation but certainly there
is some role to be played by the faculty
or the mentors you know I think again
that's a really interesting question and
I think it goes to the heart of your
interest in science education as well
and you know the motivation you know 90%
of it has to be self motivation you have
to want to try to do the work you're
doing you know my my contribution to
this is is trying to help the people in
my laboratory think creatively and
broadly about their science and going
back and forth and I sell them say no
it's always you know a back and forth
discussion of this idea or that idea and
if we want to try to address it how do
we do that and so though it's then that
interaction which I think helps with the
motivation but but I really want people
to come into lab who want to be creative
and I understand that that we're it's
such a privileged position to be able to
be in to be able to be in a laboratory
to think about a question for the first
time you'll be able to address it for
the first time and when you get that
data to be the first person in the world
to ever think about it and to be able to
try to understand what it might need and
so that's the type of motivation I want
people to have and it's what I try to
help them with in terms of our in lab
discussions I know like you're busy with
all you outlook and all those things so
if doing
spare time like how do you spend that
like what are your hobbies on domestics
well you know that that's yeah you're
right there's not a lot a lot of times
oh my son again
yeah alright let me see if I can I
switch to another camera let's see if
this one will work okay
I'm really not sure why why it's lagging
so much yeah
turn off a few of my other programs okay
okay
yeah I'm sorry for some reason I'm just
not getting this yeah you can go back to
the same or the camera yeah that's what
I'm trying to do yeah I don't really
know what the problem is
sorry it just doesn't seem to be coming
on oh really
well um yeah I don't know it's very odd
let me let me see if I can try this from
this other from my laptop okay
if you tell you what when they go out of
Google and go back in okay
okay okay let me try that
yeah we have some technical problems so
we should be able to get it going within
no time
now here you go yeah so um so yeah and
in terms of hobbies and think that I've
done in the past no III do I don't have
a lot of time for these things now but I
do like to be working and and so I enjoy
doing that joy going down into my
workshop in my basement and listen to
music well well I make things I enjoy
reading no I read extensively although
not as much as I'd like
listen to me music primarily jazz is
also one of my love's in the past I've
gotten a variety of things I played
rugby in the past and I would play judo
for many years I was a guide for an
organization called international field
studies for spelunking which is cave
exploring so lots of things like that
that that that I've done in the past but
these days you know it's it's a lot of
lab work mostly and not nearly as much
time for these other things okay
and what got you interested in
single-cell analysis in the seulji next
question and yeah again a great question
so that was when I was a postdoc at
Stanford I was involved with a group
that was interested in trying to do
analysis of circadian rhythms and
there's a region of the brain called the
suprachiasmatic nucleus which is
involved in regulation of circadian
rhythms we now know that every cell has
a circadian clock the back then we were
interested in this one sort of region of
the brain and so we were working in the
mouse system and to be able to generate
enough tissue to get enough RNA to do
the standard type of molecular biology
and library making required the use
literally of hundreds of animals
yeah because SVN in such a small area
and so not wanting to do that not
wanting to use so many different animals
I then decided to try to figure out how
we could adopt molecular biology
procedures to decrease the number of
animals and increase the sensitivity in
resolution like analysis by working at
the level of a single cell we now spend
a lot of time working on some cellular
monkey biology as well but um but that
was really the motivation with trying to
use fewer animals for the research and
to try to get as much information from
the system as we can yeah can you please
go ahead and present Killick with that
there's a that sure so what I thought I
would do is present some of the work
from my laboratory over the last couple
of years this yeah okay and I'm gonna go
through this relatively quickly I'm sure
everyone get off and have a late
breakfast or early breakfast event above
where you are meeting and so but I want
to give you sort of a flavor for some of
the things that single cell biology has
been telling us so the driving question
for my laboratory is really this and
that's how is variation in cell biology
important to the functioning of a cell
and so it's illustrated by this saison
84 there's seven different apples they
all look similar but they're all also
distinct there's there's biological
variation and so the question for us is
what does that biological variation mean
to me to sell itself other cells into
the organism so normally I would present
this in PowerPoint mode I'm not doing
that now because of the limitations of
the system but this is an animated slide
there are lots of animated slides that
aren't going to show the animations
because of how I'm showing this but this
is just sort of a rationale for doing
single-cell analysis on the left you can
see you can see a brain where you can
see areas such as sort of the horseshoe
shape in the middle which is called the
hippocampus and the right hand side you
can see sort of look dark tracts
to cerebellum so here what we've done as
a technique we developed several years
ago called its IQ transcription which is
cDNA synthesis right in the tissue
section so what we've done is we take a
fixed tissue we put a primer on it'll
that primer will bind to the RNA and
then we can make cDNA right in that
fixed tissue and you can see areas like
the hippocampus and the cerebellum where
there's a lot but a black signal and
that means that there's a lot of RNA
there and so if you go to the upper
right panel you can see three areas in
that panel that have a lot of white
grains and so this is at the level of
single cell so if we zoom in with a
microscope we can see those three cells
with a lot of white grains and those are
RNA transcripts for a particular RNA we
were known interested in and what this
shows us is that those three cells all
have this one RNA and there are a
hundred other cells represented by the
brown circles in the picture that do not
have this RNA so there's variation
between these cells that have the RNA
there's variation between the cell that
has the RNA and cell it doesn't and so
the question is how variable are they
and can we develop techniques that allow
us to give you that analysis that's
where single-cell analysis comes in and
Maya nurses have been primarily the CNS
so there's some facts about the CNS that
in the lower right hand panel that that
show why single cell analysis is
important one of the things I want to
highlight though for this audience which
may not be a real neuroscience audience
is a almost all of this work is be done
and collaborate with my friend and
colleague professor Zhang Yun Kim
hyun-jung is a computational biologist
and the distinction I'd like to make is
a bioinformatics Asst is somebody in
might teach you French language whereas
a computational biologist is somebody
would teach you French literature that's
really how joonyoung and I interact with
respect to all the work that is done in
in in in these particular experience
we'll do an experiment he'll help us
analyze it we then go back and do better
experience based upon the analysis and
all of you interested in genomics need
to interact with computational
biologists in a productive way
[Applause]
I like showing that slide because my son
who is a classicist help me do the
translation on this this is a passage
from a book that Robert Hooke published
called micrographia in 1665 this was
commissioned by the Royal Society it was
one of the first scientific bestsellers
2,000 copies of this book sold within
two years and Latin was a language at
the time and when this is translated
what you can see is using the microscope
it means ended on the right hand side
you can see that he was able to look at
cork and he called the pores that he saw
cells and that was the first description
of an individual so what we call us so
now as a cell and so they would hook a
couple years later followed this with
his description of live cells called
anima culés
and then over the course of the fall 950
years various people contributed
development of modern cell theory and I
would argue that it's the elaboration of
modern cell theory which gave rise to
all the modern molecular biology
including the elaboration of darwin's
hypothesis for natural selection and
without the idea of the cell as an
entity in and of itself I don't think
any other scientific discoveries would
have been possible
an additional rationale for looking at
single-cell analysis is provided by this
slide so if you look at the left-hand
portion of this you can see five blue
cells and if we're interested in the red
triangular RNA if you take all these
cells isolating the RNA from all those
cells which is what we used to do before
single-cell analysis all the RNA would
be combined in a test tube and the
triangular RNAs are not visible because
they're below the level of sensitivity
of the technology on the right hand side
you can see five cells and each of those
has different amounts of the triangular
RNA so if you take all of those cells
and homogenize them and look in the RNA
you might think that each cell has two
copies of RNA whereas you can see some
cells have none other cells have large
amounts so single cell analysis allows
you to resolve those issues you can see
whether or not it has a large number of
rnas or no rnas so it allows you to
understand that complexity it's a shame
that the animations aren't working for
this slide but you you can do single
cell biology now for a variety of
different cell biological processes you
can look at genomic DNA in a single cell
and look at variation based upon single
nucleotide polymorphisms you can look at
aspects of chromatin dynamics single so
epigenomics single cell transcriptome
eggs which are what I'm going to
primarily tell you about we've done a
lot of work looking at single cell mRNA
translation as we were the first group
to show that up on transfection of RNA
into cells and into dendrites then that
RNA could actually be translated into
protein and but i'm not going to show
you any of that work today single cell
kept at home because proteomics is a
developing field just a single cell
entomology and metabolomic SAR and then
single cell functional genomics we spend
a lot of time in my laboratory on but
i'm not gonna have any time today to
tell you about that but i think it's
critically important as you develop all
these transcriptomics profiles they're
literally petabytes of data of single
cell transcript omics data and tissue
transcript omics data and what most
people do is they look at one gene at a
time based upon that transcriptomics
data so figuring out ways of looking at
multiple genes simultaneously it's going
to allow you to understand what that
that expression profile is telling you
and so figuring out how that you
function kinetics of that level is
important this all gives rise to this
idea of cellular phenotype and phenotype
is a much more complex process idea that
i think many people think it is when you
think about phenotype it's a function of
the cell that you're interested in if
it's function is a function of thats our
ken in the morning or ken at night is a
function in that cell when it is two
weeks old or in that cell is seventy
years old in the human brain and so so
phenotype is very complex and i think as
we talk about phenotype and elaborate
this idea over the coming years we need
to figure out how to how to describe we
need an oncology community that just
doesn't exist at the moment with this
said
again this is an animated slide normally
there's a real move towards high
throughput with people doing I - but
sequencing the large numbers of cells -
per cell biology and that really is
important you need to be able to
generate a large amounts of data but at
the same time it's critically important
to do height thought but it's not
sufficient to just do you know 10,000
cells and sequence them you have to try
to plan that experiment so you get the
most information out of it and if that
looks the most information requires
doing 10,000 cells simultaneously at
load readouts meaning you don't detect
all the RNAs then you do the experiment
that way if however the experiment
requires you to look at transcription
factors which are often low abundance
RNAs
then you need to sequence to a much
greater depth and that requires less
throughput and higher I see higher
sequencing ability so you have to think
about the experiment you're doing and
and and and really put some thought into
it again the next series of slides are
our animated slide so you're going to
miss that but I'll quickly flick through
these so when you think about
single-cell analysis what you want to be
able to do is to detect and quantify the
chemicals in a single cell so this is a
neuron and we'd like to be able to look
at the genomic DNA sequence which is in
the pink nucleus area of the cell we'd
like to be able to look at the RNA which
would be in the blue or the green area
of the cell which is in dendrites in the
cell soma we'd like to be able to look
at proteins and metabolites and we like
to look at all those quantitatively and
at the same time in the single cell so
that's called multimodal analysis so
that we can actually not just look at
the transcriptome or look at the
transcriptome protium the Trinity and
the metemma all in the cell to get us
and I'd give us an idea where the
biology that cell really is we'd also be
able to like we would also like to be
able to look at organelles in the cell
now you have translation occurring in
them right or itself soma splice he can
occur in the nucleus of the cell or the
cytoplasm we were the first group to
show site about Nix placing we'd like to
be able to look at transcription and
chromatin that's in the nucleus though
so we need to be able to look at these
sub cellular structures ideally we'd
like
look at all of these simultaneously so
DNA and RNA and crooking that I could be
able to look at translation as it's
occurring transcription this is
occurring and basically if we can do all
of this then we'd have the ultimate
characterization the cell and well
that's not possible today
it will be possible within the next few
years to be able to do all of these
things many of us are working on
techniques will marry these different
analysis procedures so that we do this
at a quantitative reliable manner one of
the other things I want to highlight
though is as I say this now there is
some cellular biology associated with
this particularly with cell like a
neuron so you have these red rectangular
areas where you have dendrites so that's
one component of the cell and the
biology and the dendrite can be
different than the biology in the blue
rectangle which is a cell soma and you
can also have different biologies
occurring within the nucleus of the cell
so you really do have to be able to not
just quantitate these processes and
chemicals in the whole cell you need to
have a look at some cellular sites and
much of my lab is devoted to doing that
type of analysis to be able to do multi
modal analysis you need to be able to
figure out how to isolate your samples
in quantitative and then again I'm not
going to go into this in any detail now
but among the types of things that one
can do with a single cell there's low
hanging fruit that's very easy to detect
that one basically everyone who does
single cell analysis can do this and
this is actually potential grow targets
we did this work a few years ago now and
it was among the first it was a first
paper describing the transcriptome a
type of neuron called a serotonergic
neuron these neurons are involved in a
variety of different functions within
the cell or within the organism and
there there are melodies a certain
neurons including depressive behaviors
social anxiety a whole host of other
types of neurological psychiatric
illnesses that you know are impacted by
certain urgent neural function so
understanding these neurons is important
to understanding the illnesses I would
argue
so what we share Oh back at University
of chop and and took a mouse that had
sarakin nergic neurons labeled with a
marker that would allow those neurons to
be visible so this is a live slice
through a region of the brain where
certain nergic neurons are so the yellow
cells are live cells that are spared
energic so we can take a patch pipette
which is a glass capillary tube and go
down to an individual cell that has a
yellow color and isolate the RNA from
that cell so you can see in panel B
there is the yfp fluorescence there's a
little micropipette or a stick that's
poking that cell from the lower right
hand corner around for four clocks on
the clock dial and so we can poke that
cell and pull the RNA into the pipette
and so we know we add the RNA from a
single surgeon or jig neuron that way
and when we do this we can sequence it
and we can identify a whole host of
different RNAs within the cell and among
the RNAs that we're interested in are
those GPCRs g-protein coupled receptors
where do our receptors on the cell
surface of the cells and every major
pharmaceutical company in the world as a
GPC our program where they try to
identify ligands and targets that bind
to these receptors prior to these
studies for these cells we knew that
there were three GPT RS on these cells
by virtue of doing the transcriptomics
we now know that each of these cells has
RNA from 200 different GPCR genes so the
RNA is present that doesn't mean the RNA
is made in protein or is mainly protein
the protein is functional but it housing
these cells have the capacity to respond
to these particular ligands and so this
time this data is only generated by
doing single cell analysis and when we
look through these lists of GPCRs we
identified histamine receptor as one
that we were interested in and we were
able to show that these cells
endogenously were atomically inhibited
by histamine so this was the first proof
that there was a tonic inhibition in
these neurons bye-bye histamine
and so so this allows us to identify
those those receptors and then you do
some interesting biology associated with
it and these studies are continuing in
our lab and many of it lives around the
world now one of the questions is is
transcriptome variability important to
cellular function and so I started the
presentation that way we have lots of
ways of looking at this and again the
animations are not going to come through
on this unfortunately but but if you
look at this slide along the top you see
purple line called for serotonergic
neurons a light blue line for cortical
pyramidal cells a red line for
cardiomyocytes a brown line for brown
adipocytes and below each of those lines
are columns in each of those comes it's
a single cell from that cell type and
what you can see is the neurons surgeon
urging neurons and the hippocampal
pyramidal cortical the corticon
hippocampal pyramidal cells Express niro
no markers and those are the yellow and
brown areas below those those lines but
they also expressed some cardiomyocyte
markers that you see as the red line
below that the cardiomyocytes which are
over a little bit over for the right if
you look down those columns you can see
the cardiomyocyte markers come up high
but also some of the neuronal markers
are coming up and if you look at all the
cardio myocyte markers here you look at
neurons markers you can see that from
column to column they're not the same
they're different gradients of color
that means you're different amounts of
RNA for those and that tells us that the
cells are variable in the amount of RNA
Express so even for a particular cell
type like a cardio myocyte there's
variability in the markers that are
known to be present in cardiac myocytes
and so one of the things that this
highlights and everyone doing single
cell transcriptome because no matter
what so time is seeing this variability
now but one of the thing I want to
highlight is we used to describe neurons
versus another cell type called
astrocytes as astrocytes would express
something called GAAP which is a marker
of astrocytes and neurons were expressed
neural filament which is present in
neurons it turns out that I can find gf
AP RNA in some neurons I can find who
were filament RNA in some astrocytes
and these markers you know all the work
is funded in the past has been right but
it's been the level of sensitivity if
you do em you know site or chemistry or
you grind up a tissue you don't have
single-cell resolution and you're going
to miss those lower abundance RNAs that
are present so there are very few
individual cell type-specific genes one
of the things that it's important to
take note of with respect to this is as
you develop transgenic models and try to
develop a cell type specific promoter
many of those promoters when you go to
level single cell or express it
alternative subtypes you have to be
extremely careful I think as you develop
those models and says there's a lot of
other biology that one can develop and
this is all published so I'm not going
to go through this in detail one of the
things I do want to mention though is
when you look at gene RNAs
gene transcribed RNA is in cells there's
a certain gene model that people always
look at you know where the five prime is
the exons of three prime n but what this
data shows and this is all public so you
can look paper up is that even within a
particular cell type light such as
cardiomyocytes a pyramidal neurons you
can find different three prime ends for
the RNAs so the same gene but different
three prime ends in the three prime end
of the RNA can have impact in terms of
how stable and RNA is or even the
function the RNA it's three prime n can
have different exons and even within an
individual cell you can have different
three prime ends utilize so this is
telling something about the molecular
biology of the cell that we did not know
before single cell biology and I think
is again going to be important for how
we we develop the genomics of the
nervous system in some types of course
we'd like inaudible biology
simultaneously and we want to be able to
do this in human cells so while we do a
lot of mouse work and it's a great model
system we've also worked in the
drosophila system with Amita Sehgal and
other systems with other people
including some very interesting work and
quail with rusty Lansford at USC we
really like to be able to work in the
human system even though we work with
model systems there's no so like the
human cell and many things that you see
in a mouse cell or just a standard model
system are not going to be the same and
even
so so we need to be able to look in the
human as well so we were able to be able
to work with a neurosurgeon group here
of 10 and we have an extensive
collaboration so that the time of
neurosurgery tissue that is removed
sentence for a glioblastoma or
interventional neurosurgery for epilepsy
as those manipulations are done and the
tissue is removed we take that tissue
and it comes to our laboratory and what
we've been able to do is we were able to
do the first human neuronal adult
culture from these tissues that we take
human library human brain tissue
associate the cells under certain
conditions and culture adult human
neurons from tissue from there was
isolated from 70 year old patients and
so again this paper has published this
past year and these are some human
neurons that we have in culture and if
you're going to develop drugs and try to
understand human neurobiology after work
with the human system because they're
just some things that are going to be
unique to the human cells and so so
we've been able to do this we can record
currents from these cells and do a lot
of biology on these cells and here maybe
this animation will show here we have
human neurons and culture and we are
stimulating with various types of drugs
such as glutamate or with potassium and
other types of markers that oh one of
these show that cause calcium to come
into the cell and and so the lower
right-hand panel shows us cells that are
h.p responsive or potassium responsive
glutamate responsive and so now we can
go to those individual live human
neurons and pull the RNA from those
individually responsive cells in the
like that and try to understand how the
physiology and responsiveness to these
drugs correlates with the transcriptome
of the cell the main biological insight
in addition we've been able to learn how
to culture these neurons long-term and
in fact we can actually get neurospheres
developed from adult human brain so what
you can see here is
for three months in culture we have
neurospheres that are developed and from
these neurospheres new neurons and
astrocytes actually are generated even
again from the 70 year old adult brain
and this is actually an area called the
hippocampus I'm sorry from the cortex
where people had not thought that this
or the tissue where where this could be
done and so this gives us a lot of hope
for the ability to manipulate the human
and all central nervous system in a way
that will allow neurons to regenerate
and perhaps we conduct and and
recapitulate the function that that some
disease cells might actually have
subsumed in our cultures in it we have
neurons we have astrocytes we have a
variety of different human subtypes
again you can look this paper up I'm not
going to go through this in detail this
is just a transcript that makes
signatures of these cells and when we
have these transcriptomes we and then
try to understand how very well these
cells are from one another and again
this is all published this is just a
statistical way of looking at these five
different cell types and showing how
different they are from one another and
how similar they are to one another
within cell types and we can also look
at RNAs that are not mRNAs this is
actually these are long non-coding RNAs
these are regulatory RNAs that serve a
variety of roles with themselves and
some of these RNA seem to be cell
type-specific if you look in panel C the
first link which is 13 14 you can see
way out at the right-hand side of that a
red arrow pointing to the line and
that's a link RNA that's greatly
enriched in astrocytes and present very
low abundance and these four the cell
types and there are other RNAs such as
the lower one that seems to be present
at relatively high abundance in all cell
types so again the transcriptomics gives
you insight into specific ones that one
might want to look at you can also look
at pre micro RNA so micro RNA does not
would not be isolated in our procedure
but a pre micro RNA would be and we've
been able to identify some pre micro
rna's let's see maybe relatively we're
saying endothelial cells such as four
145 in other words that that are
distributed throughout cells and so this
is a particular type of a lot of us our
RNA type that a lot of us are interested
in
because again of its regulatory role in
modulating RNA expression and protein
expression so what I've shown you mostly
is RNA from cells that are dispersed in
cell culture what we really like to be
able to do a look at RNAs in their
natural micro environment where neuron
is connected to other neurons and
astrocytes and then new lluvia selves
are interacting with those neurons where
we don't take the cell and disperse it
from the brain we want those those
connections and remain intact so some of
the early work I showed you where we
took the certain nergic cell RNA that
was from a live mouse brain section and
we found those cells through
fluorescence microscopy took a biped and
went through the tissue I said the RNA
but we wanted to do and develop a
procedure that was not invasive like
that we wanted to develop procedure that
didn't require the pipette to isolate
the RNA so working with my chemistry
colleague Ivan Moscone
mama husky who is a professor in
chemistry we develop a procedure called
Chiba
hey what Hema does again this is an
animated slide so I'm afraid that's
gonna be lost on you is it's a way of
isolating RNA from live cells and what
this slide is intended to do this to
show you how you isolate RNA from pools
of cells and tissue single cells in
culture or single cells and fix tissue
or single cells in live tissue and so so
I just show you a little bit of some of
the Teva work so the teamwork is based
upon this particular compound so this is
the complex compound that we synthesized
in in in chemistry and the idea behind
this compound is if you look at look at
it on the structure you see a cpp list
it's sort of in the middle of slide on
the chemical structure CPP is it called
cell penetrating peptide and this is a
peptide that when connected to this
molecule will carry this molecule into
any cell and once it's inside the cell
it sits there and it sits there because
of the chemical structure you see a poly
u which is in blue and two short
stretches of poly a those poly a's bind
to the poly use through hydrogen bonding
those are nucleotides the poly a's are
separated with that red chemical
photoactivatable compound and the use
and the aides are separated from each
other by that same photoactivatable
chemical compound beside the blue used
on the left hand side of it is a
fluorescent molecule called site 3 and
both side the green a's in the bottom
there's a fluorescent molecule called
size 5 so when this body goes in the
cell the side 3 and the sci-fi were very
close to one another we have what's
called a fret signal so you can see them
interacting and and then when we hit
this compound with light in the cell the
red molecules between the blue and the
and the green using a s and then between
the green aids break apart and where
those break apart then the eight is fall
away from the use the use can then bind
to the a containing RNAs in the cell the
fret signal is lost so we now know we've
activated its compound and the Teva
compound basically will bind to the
endogenous RNA when this is hit with
light then and this is in my cells in
real time and then what we can do is we
grind up that tissue and you can see
next to the top fluorescent molecule
there's a molecule called biotin so the
biotin Teva you stretch will bind to the
poly a plus RNA in the cell and then we
can isolate the poly a plus RNA keep it
complex by using something that will
bind to the biotin so again this
animation is not going to show up
unfortunately but this is just an
animation sort of showing this going to
sell activating it in the cell it
basically sits in the cell until you
activate it you then lose your fret
signal and you can isolate RNA from that
live cell and this paper is published
about two years ago now this works
excuse me in a number of different cells
red is allotted where you load a cell
with the tiba compound where you see the
fret signal when we hit it with light to
activate it the fresh needle comes apart
and we now have a green signal so now
that activated TV compound can bind RNA
in that lead cell and we were able to
show that we can do this for RNA in the
mouse
slice preparation hippocampal cells and
their number of different features of
this that that I think might be
interesting
again this is an animated slide so
unfortunate it's not going to show up
but one of the things I asked my
audiences is say you have a hippocampal
cell and dispersed cell culture or you
have a hippocampal cell in the live
hippocampus slice which of those cells
is going to contain more RNAs and it
turns out that the cell in the
hippocampus slice has about 9,000 RNAs
expressed the cell in dispersed cell
culture has 12,000 genes expressed so
when you remove this out from the
natural micro environment you get more
genes Express well that's telling us is
the natural micro environment serves as
an inhibitor of gene expression it
suppresses the the gene genes that are
expressed from that hippocampal cell and
so that's one way the central nervous
system controls the function of these
cells and again though there's a variety
of things that we could discuss but
since I can't do the animation thing
just skip over it we have a course
applied this to human tissue so this is
actually human neuronal tissue from a
patient presented with hydrocephaly and
this is a piece of the tissue that was
surgically removed and we can take this
a new life slices through the human
brain tissue activate an individual cell
and do the transcript domains and this
has been a great collaboration with the
neurosurgeons at Penn and then it's been
phenomenal be able to work with Sean
Grady and his team of neurosurgeons not
only can we look at the RNA in
individual cells but we can look at read
in the cell so one area that's been
really important interesting to us is
being able to look at RNA in dendrites
and and so I highlighted the dendrites
in one of the early slides but the
dendrites receive input from presynaptic
neurons from the axons and when an axon
a bucks on to a dendrite you form a
synapse and said that synapse
we're aspects of something called
learning and memory occur every
neurological disease known to man as
after fien dendrites and axons and so
this is a critical subcellular site
that's important for how neurons
interact with their their neighboring
cells and environment so we wanted to
look at the
RNAs that are present within those the
subcellular regions we knew the protein
sentences worth important in these eras
from the original work of Ossie Stewart
then we followed this up by showing the
Trent RNAs can be translated but to look
at the transcript under the in these
individual cells what we did initially
well that's and we have several papers
published on this is in our culture
neurons we would remove the cell body
and that leaves the fine hair like
structures which you can see in the
right-hand panel then we use these glass
capillary tubes basically that to suck
up an individual isolated dendrite and
then we can view transcriptomics on that
dendrite and identify the RNAs that are
present there and again we have several
papers published on this but using the
Kiba compound what we'd like to be able
to do is look at dendrites in the live
slice preparation where these neurons
the dendrites are connected to other
other neurons so here you can see in the
mouse slice preparation we activate the
Kiba compound in multiple dendrites in
the second set of panels and an
individual dendritic third set of panels
and at an individual dendritic spine
which is where an axon of bucks to form
a synapse in the lower panels and this
uh this is possible because of the
resolution of light light will allow us
to focus its beam add an individual area
of a cell activate the Kiba compound and
the only RNA that will be isolated is in
that green area in that activated cell
so we look at RNA in these different
subset of sites now and this is just an
example of uncaging in different areas
and so to show that this can be done in
the evening case and there are various
bits of data that I'm just going to skip
over with respect to this but it's a
more current work what we've been doing
is looking at human cerebellar Purkinje
cells these tissues come from
glioblastoma
that that you know are pervasive in
cerebellum unfortunately and what you
can see is in these live turrets
cerebellar tissue slices that we can
activate the compound so if you look say
at VR you tu-95
you can see psy 3 and psy five kage in
that one set of neurons and then lower
panel you can see that when we uncage at
the site three fluorescent signal
increases showing us of the first
the sci-fi decreases so we've activated
in that one dendrite in the live human
slice preparation and that's her Bela
Purkinje cell and we can now I slay the
RNA we've done this and we looked at
libraries we sequenced many of these and
we can identify the RNAs that are
present in these different substituted
sites so this top set of panels in that
one dendrite from that you and
cerebellar Purkinje cell we have 533 RNA
GI subjects from that individual
dendrite and you can see the number that
we identified the other two
interestingly some of these are the same
as what we identify in the mouse or or
the dispersed human cells but many of
them are different and what that's
telling us is the connections and the
interactome is really important for
elaboration of the functional dendrite
in these systems so we're really excited
by these data the last bit of data that
I want to show you some more recent work
or some ongoing recent work again this
is an animated slide but one we're
interest in the cell biology what the
cell is essentially the emergent
property or the function of the cellular
structures organelles so a cell is more
than the sum of the parts is what this
means
but the parts are necessary to create
that then that function itself so what
we'd like to be able to do is not only
look at the RNA or the biology of the
whole cell we'd like to be able to look
the RNA in the Golgi apparatus
so the RNA and cell membrane or the RNA
and the lysosome of the mitochondria or
we'd like to be able look at other
aspects that do genomics Tamizh
individual some other sites and and by
doing that then we hope to understand
those subsets of their constituents and
how they work together then to create
the emergent property of a cell's
function so we just published a paper
about I think a month and a half ago now
where we can look at individual single
mitochondria where we isolated
individual mitochondria from live cells
live neurons and astrocytes and then we
sequence the genomic DNA from that
individual mitochondria and the idea is
we want to look at mutations in the
mitochondrial DNA between cells then
also within us all because an individual
cell can then literally have many
hundreds of mitochondria or all those
mitochondria the same or are they
different
they're the different how different are
they and do they contribute to the
function of the the summation of the
function in mitochondria and the
function of the neuron all of us think
of the mitochondrion some powerhouses
sell but they do many other things as
well so this just shows mitochondria in
astrocytes and neurons just one way of
this is alive mhm and and one could
again the animations aren't going to
work unfortunately but you can see each
of the red spots in and the sort of the
dispersed flat cells is an individual
mitochondria and then some of the green
neurons you can see mitochondria all
around the cell Silva and some of them
in the end rights and so these
mitochondria move within the cell they
respond to different types of stimuli
and are actually quite dynamic this is
actually let me see if this wall play
didn't see miter-cut live mitochondria
moving within a cell and some of them
moved quite a distance some of them
tears with other mitochondria and and so
it's really a phenomenal biological
process that's going on and we can
isolate an individual one of these
mitochondria and many of these from the
same cell you try to look at how they
might might function the mitochondrial
genome is about 16,000 bases long and
and so that's what we're sequencing
we're sequencing the genome of these
mitochondria so about 16,000 bases and
there are mutations associated with
these different bases that are important
for aspects of mitochondrial disease and
many these mitochondria disease have a
low prevalence they don't affect a lot
of people many of them are categorized
as orphan diseases but I think it's
arguable most people would argue this
now the mitochondria are involved in
many other illnesses so whether a direct
mutation is associated with the Nonna's
dysfunction in mitochondria almost
certainly is associated with every
neurological illness you know you have
decreased mitochondrial function making
it a cell more likely to be responsive
to some type of bad challenge or some
type of dysfunction and so how that
might be impacted by mutations in the
mitochondrial genomic DNA is a
critically important
question one of the complications of
this is each mitochondria can have one
genome or ten or more genomes so when
you I say the mitochondria you might
have 10 mitochondrial genomes so looking
at individual mitochondrial genome
variation becomes quite complex so this
is a difficult set of studies again you
can look the paper up I'm not gonna
belabor you with the issues associated
with it but suffice it to say that we
figured out how to do this type of
analysis so we can look at these
mutations and look at single nucleotide
variation and the way we do this is you
can label this the mitochondria with
live dies so this again these are live
mitochondria you can see their
fluorescence in these mitochondria and
you can if you look at a B and C you can
see the red arrow on panel B pointed in
the mitochondria and we can do to take a
pipette down to that individualize cell
and cool that mitochondrion into it like
that independent of the other
mitochondria so it's brute force
isolation of this mitochondria and we
can then sequence the DNA from that
individual mitochondria the way we've
done this initially through this
particular PCR protocol again you can
look it up we have other ways of doing
this now that I think are even more
robust and more exciting but when we do
this we can look at the distribution of
mitochondria gyah
mutations across the length of the
mitochondria and between cells and again
this is all described in the paper and
so so we do find variation so all
mitochondria within an individual cell
are not the same and the extent of that
variation is actually quite intriguing
and exciting for us to be able to
investigate this is actually I love this
slide this is actually a human adult
neuron that had been in culture for
about I think four months we stained
this with a guy from mitochondria and we
could go into the dendritic area of this
cell and pull individual mitochondria
from each of these boxty areas and so we
can take these individual mitochondria
from this mitochondrion neuron and
sequencing and so we've done 10 from
this individual cell and again we can
look at mitochondria single nucleotide
variation across the length of
mitochondria width between cells and
within cells and again if you're
interested in this you can look the data
but there are different types of
mutations who have identified we've
identified the frequency of these
mutations and these mutations exist in a
number of different genes involved
different biologies including ATP
generation energy utilization import and
export of chemicals within the
mitochondria and we think these
mutations are going to be important for
how these mitochondria then interact
with the nucleus those complex
communication between nucleus of the
cell and the mitochondria of the cell
and and these mutations are allowing us
to try to investigate that in a
systematic way this leads us to
following up on the idea of others so
this is not our idea there's been this
idea in mitochondrial field the
mutations build up over time and reach
sort of a critical busy threshold and
when it reaches that threshold then
disease can then manifest itself and so
by doing single cell mitochondrial
sequencing and looking at all the
mitochondria feeds individual cells I
think we're going to be able to
understand these mutational loads in a
way the population studies would not
allow us and trying to understand the
impact on aging and other types of
mitochondrial disease associated
biology's one of the intriguing things
that came out of these data is it looks
like the disease the mutation frequency
is different between mice and rats are
tiny mice and humans so that that I
think the ways in which these mutations
are generated involved I like the need
to actually be able to do these
experiments in humans my next I have
three more slides and then I I like
showing this again this is an animated
slide but I just want to highlight you
know I've gone through a lot of things
very quickly but it's a so dynamical
States the results modern world of
biology whether you look at the RNA the
protein the Telmo whether you look at
transcription or translation or RNA
degradation all of these go together to
create the dynamics cell and and I made
it look easy but there's a lot of
failures are described as well and so
one of my favorite short story authors
is Alice Munro and when she won the
Nobel Prize
in 2013 she gave an interview thing New
Yorker and the statement was in this
this interview the complexity of things
the things within things just seems to
be endless I mean nothing is easy
nothing is simple and that was true for
Alice Munro in terms of the complexity
of variety and that's true for any of us
look into the complexity of single
something like your biology and genomics
it's not simple and but you need to
generate the data so that you can then
ask informed in interesting biologies
and questions of those biology and this
is only going to you know not only going
to be possible in dispersed cells but
also in lie brains where you can look at
different areas such as these dendritic
areas where you can see different spines
in this region and and and snow you need
to be able to develop techniques that
allow you to do this in a multi-modal
multicellular way and then finally now
these are some of the people that have
been involved in this work and and so
Jackie Moore's did some of the
mitochondrial work with Washu and
Jennifer saying the the serotonergic
work Kevin Mir Cheryl was involved in
aspects actually discussing a Kevin's
work je Li has been involved in all
aspects that the Teva work and the work
of the other people I didn't describe
today J and so is an associate professor
in pharmacology the biomechanics expert
in in all the M components describe Jin
Yong Kim is a computational biologist a
colleague and people in his lab in my
lab were constantly together to try to
improve our biology and to understand
the biology there's been a great
collaboration and we've been fortunate
to be able to work with a whole host of
collaborators both within Penn and at
various universities around around the
world to try to utilize their insights
and biology is to try to understand the
types of questions we can address so so
that's really after the presentation
though that's that's what what I wanted
to try to describe in terms of
this type of work there's a lot of other
stuff that could done oh I think he is
shed I guess just been shattered yeah
here we go there there's a lot of lot of
other types of biology that can be done
there a lot of exciting things that I
didn't describe that are ongoing now in
my lab and other labs and I just
encourage all of you to follow the field
if you're not doing single cell biology
I'd encourage you to do it it'll help
advance the science that you're doing
doing there are types of initiatives
funding initiatives around the country
around the world one of the things I do
is I'm on something called the multi
council working group which is the
advisory committee to the brain
initiative there are I think 12 of us on
this committee and they're constantly
RFA's going out for single-cell analysis
both from the genomics to the functional
level and so I encourage you to look at
that there's a human cell mapping hub
map from NIH there are all types of
private initiatives there's the
International cell census initiative and
there's a lot of opportunity to take
your science of allowable single cell if
that level one Hance the types of
biology and help you address the
questions you're interested in
addressing and of course never hesitate
to email me email me call me should you
have any questions about the
presentation or any aspect of this work
so thank you so much thanks thanks Jim I
really appreciate it's a really
wonderful overview of whatever the
things happening in your lab and
analysis so I have a couple of questions
maybe one one is regarding like you have
looked at various RNAs in different
areas the question is like there is a
more or less like that is what like the
people are looking at right now
scientists are look at this RNA is more
or like you'll be able to eat this thing
of solana genomics you will be able to
see very low amounts of but does it mean
sometimes like this low means like see
it all depends on like how they are
transcribed so sometimes like even if
there is a bulk amount of RNA India
very slowly so end product is basically
the proteins which control the various
cellular aspects so like does it help to
do the proteins along with this to get a
better understanding on what's that mean
in the cell yes so a couple of answers
to that again that's really a great
question and one that we all all of us
in the field of single-cell analysis are
interested in so transcription is
thought to occur in verse so that you
have no the the genes bursting in RNA
for a short time period and and that's
not to occur from most genes I'm not
sure it occurs for all genes but for
most peens and where you get most of the
regulation in terms of production of
protein is that translational regulation
so what you're suggesting is that the
protein levels may not necessarily
parallel the RNA levels and that's
exactly right so all of us look at RNA
levels all of us infer RNA abundances
from the RNA levels I think there's some
caveats to that I think one has to be
careful how one quantitate their RNA
seek and and keep those numbers sort of
as sort of squishy numbers if you will
because there there's a lot of
amplification associated with with RNA
seek there is some single molecule
analysis now being done that doesn't
require amplification but that's that's
not routine at the moment but yeah I
think when you have an RNA present in
the cell or in a tissue sample that does
not mean the proteins necessarily made
there a lot of people make the argument
proteins made and in fact in may or may
not key just tells you the cell has the
capacity to make that protein so as you
can couple it with protein analysis that
will always provide you more insight
into biology of the cells excuse me and
other question is the dendrites like
dendritic analysis you had done like
dendritic cell sometimes so big like the
different RNAs expressed at different
levels and different areas within again
died so have you been able to interpret
that or look into that yeah he is
exactly right and we've done a lot of in
our we haven't published any of this
we've looked at different branches of
individual dendrites different areas of
the dendrite and and different sub
cellular compartments within the
dendrite it I won't describe it in
detail but yeah it's exactly right that
follows on the beautiful work I think it
can Co seek and others who have looked
at this type of thing in the past and
and so yeah we've been able to isolate
its different regions and analyze them
and are working to try understand what
it's telling us about the biology of
neuronal interactions now and the lastly
coming to a latter portion of you that
talk on the mitochondria so within a
cell there are hundreds of mitochondria
like you find all these gene mutations
so is there any number of like is there
any percentage of mitochondria which are
like defect you're like mutated which
are not like anything has been that
appears it's really an exciting question
to ask and quite frankly we don't know
the answer yet so it's an area that
we're keenly interested in there's you
know we actually were able to show this
but we were not the first to publish on
it unfortunately but it turns out that
mitochondria can move from an astrocyte
into a neuron and sprain genomic
information from one cell to another
cell and and so so I think there's a lot
of there's more specificity to
mitochondria that I think we ever
thought before the extent of that
specificity is unclear at the moment to
us but we're actively looking at that
and trying to understand what it might
be so yeah I think it's a great error
for future investigation so with that I
think we will end up this hangout thank
you so much Jim it's really nice to have
you on and that we look forward to more
of your work and more of these hangouts
feel free to get in touch with me if you
think there is some interesting result
we can just do a handout any time thank
you and I want to also thank you for
doing this I think science education and
promoting science across different
disciplines and and you know platforms
such as the internet like this is just
critically important so thank you for
your effort as well take care bang
I met